[Music]
welcome back everyone we're back with
culture binge we left you for a little
bit I hope everyone knows we've been
anxious to come back we've missed you
all very much and we're back I'm your
host Michael here with wisecrack writer
editor everything man Alec and why is
greater hey and researcher
extraordinaire sir B hi how are you all
doing today I'm good I'm glad that
you're hosting instead of me you're
doing all the the heavy lifting today so
everyone please be nice to Michael burns
while he deals with this trying time now
that you said be nice they're gonna
attack me on a scale of one to ten how
much have you all missed being here and
doing this nine and a half that's great
I'm gonna go nine I'm gonna be like the
dick you know well I'm with you and and
we're excited to be back because we have
had a lot of our listeners reach out to
us via various social media mechanisms
and say they've missed this and we want
them to know we're excited you back
we're trying to get back and we are
gonna be on a new schedule now so let
you know at the top we're gonna be doing
this every other week for any listeners
in the UK we're gonna be doing it
fortnightly so you can expect that the
good part about that is that means we
will have what 14 days of cultural
content to dissect described explained
and unwrapped for everyone so that's
really great but to get started because
we missed some time let's maybe do a
quick chaps and slaps lightning round
and and by that what I want us to do is
get through as much as we can that's
taking place and the what two months
since we've been here
am i exaggerating six weeks it is hard
to remember what's happened even in the
last month but I I have a short list ok
so do you want to start let's let's
let's rip through some slaps and chaps
what do you got alright slaps I got a
lot of TV movies that we got Parks and
Rec we watching it for the second time
this year it's amazing
I saw kidding on a plane that showed Jim
Carrey where he plays a weird what's his
[ __ ] name is he like a mr. Rogers
type like an absurd sorry kidding he
plays a weird mr. mr. Rogers type guy
and the show is amazing I've only seen
the first three episodes I hope it
holds up I got a new phone so I can take
better pictures of my cat and portrait
my yeah very excited about that
I know we as a company shat on the
Oscars a few weeks ago but parasite won
best picture so that's cool and that
movies really good I went to Death
Valley again the good place the show
ended and the ending was very good and
also while I was in LA I experienced an
earthquake it was my first la earthquake
but like not the kind where anyone died
so far as I know so it was pretty cool
my horrifies other people and then for
what chaps my ass don't go and back a
little bit here this is over now I think
hopefully a potential worth Iran
that's scary baby nut don't give a [ __ ]
sorry joyousness Australia being on fire
election season America not the fact
that we have election just the fact
that's this long protracted spectacle I
hate Beetlejuice the star might explode
although maybe that slaps I don't know
someone needs to explain that to me
and also the bagel shop that I regularly
go to it has been playing nothing but
Michael Jackson on loop and at this
point I think they're trying to make
some kind of statement oh by the way but
are the bagels still good enough to
where they could keep doing that and
you're gonna keep going yeah they've
also irked me in some other ways but the
bagels are too good and listen I'm not
like oh how dare they play thriller it's
just like yeah I've been here eight
times now and every single time it's
straight Michael Jackson I feel like you
don't do that by accident no there's
some intention there that was a good
listen I think overall more slaps and
chaps which is great sir be what's been
slapping and Chapman so many things
we'll get into it what slaps the British
Royal Family is experiencing a lot of
family drama
so that's validating for me for some
reason like you could have everything
but you could still have like a [ __ ]
show of a family I really like Star Wars
I it had a problems but I still enjoyed
it I thought it was a good watch I
really liked the ending of good place I
just started to watch shits Creek which
is really really good I liked that and
then what chaps the news about Kobe
Bryant and
there are eight people in the helicopter
crash that was really sad the increasing
coronaviruses and the info Demick that's
happening the delta plane that dumped
fuel all over those kids at the
elementary school so I guess this Delta
flight was flying over LA and there were
like engine problems or some sort of
like difficulty with flying so they had
to do an emergency landing and they
dumped fuel over an elementary school
and so kids got like burns they had
breathing problems and people were
wondering like why did they do that like
why didn't they do it over like an open
field or at like a higher elevation or
something so that was like very
disappointing so I think there's like a
lawsuit now against Delta for doing that
and then the last chap is the latest
season of peaky blinders is not very
good I just started watching it was like
this is so good and then I got to the
most recent season and it's so bad wow
I've noticed a sort of morose affect of
people walking the streets of the city
so now I know it's because of peaky
blinders
they've all been disappointed yeah a mix
of the fuel dump and the the blinders
hive being upset very sorry about that
what what what about you what's what's
chapping your eyes oh what's laps thanks
for asking some of these will overlap
with your great points parasite won the
Oscar that was really exciting it was it
was a great the Oscars are so boring in
general and it was so stupid and they
shouldn't have music I know that's sort
of chaps territory but as the night went
on and we went from international to
screenplay to director and parasite
keeps winning and bong joon-ho just says
he wants to go drink and he can't when
they won Best Picture we had a little
watch party we were just screaming and
it also slaps the the cast and crew that
film were out at one of my favorite
restaurants in Koreatown until 5 a.m.
and I love that where is I think a lot
of other people they want an Oscar
they're out at some like fancy place in
like West Hollywood or the Chateau
Marmont or whatever
no bong joon-ho and friends are kicking
it in k-town and I love it
slaps the new season of Curb Your
Enthusiasm rips I do not know how Larry
David keeps keeps doing this funnier
more insightful sharper riskier than
almost anyone else making TV with the
exception of Joe Peres I think that Joe
Peres is a comedy God and the show Joe
Peres talks with you is the best thing
currently on TV not a lot of people are
watching it it's on Adult Swim check it
out two culinary things really into
vegan breakfast burritos right now I've
been scouring Los Angeles I think
they're the the best health thing I've
eaten if anyone knows of good vegan
breakfast burritos please send Rex along
with that vegan Thai food as Alec knows
I've transitioned to being kind of vegan
and and vegan Thai food is just really
good along with that some other stuff I
liked watching really like the John
Mulaney special John Mulaney and the
sack lunch gang on Netflix it's an
absurdist children special about death
anxiety I thought that was really fun
didn't travel this holiday season which
made me really happy
I'm also got engaged since we've last
been here so that's fun yeah she still
has a lot of time to you know leave the
ring and a note on the table maybe it'll
happen soon but for the time being it's
great let's get to chaps Christmas dumb
don't like it let's cancel it don't
enjoy it I think we should just have
some general we should still have work
off then but just make a new name hang
out yet do ever you want Festivus shouts
to Costanza don't like Christmas let's
not do it
New Year's Eve all so dumb don't care
about it I had a fun time because I went
to a friend's house and we just sat
there and like drink wine and ate snacks
stupid holiday too much pressure means
nothing if you want to change your life
change it today also what chaps kind of
relates to stuff you all Vall said
the news is hell the election cycle and
political stuff that's going on and and
the planet being on fire it's just hell
and the way that and this is on all
sides I'm not making a political
statement I'm making a media critique it
just all sucks all the news sucks and
it's all terrible and no matter what
they just want you to be freaking the
hell out and it's breaking news panic
story we're all gonna die I just hate it
that I can't just turn on a channel and
you know
and and and in the the sir brought this
up the Kobe News and and of course all
people that died in that helicopter
crash really tragic was a huge I don't
mean this in a glib way bummer
and a weird way to get into the start of
a new year and especially here in Los
Angeles there's a good amount of murals
of Kobe with his daughter Gianna and
it's just a sad reminder of that stuff
but a reminder as well tell the people
that we love that we love them and and
live hard while we can that's all my
slaps and chaps anyone else they say
what they wanted to add anyone think of
anything else last minute
we're slapped and chapped up sir me guys
one I knew someone is the speeches but
the celebrities give at the Oscars like
everything has to be so profound and so
insightful and it's just gross like when
Renee Zellweger was up there accepting
her speech that's the worst thing I've
ever seen watching that and let's you
know let's go this chaps as well a chaps
that we gave a Best Actor Oscar to Renee
Zellweger for a movie that no one saw
and no one saw it cuz it wasn't good and
her performance seems fine but little
zany and we need to stop this [ __ ] where
we give awards to people because they
act like other people that lived at one
point same thing with rami malek last
year great actor him putting in fake
teeth and lip-syncing to Freddie Mercury
was not a good performance we need to
stop and this is something and you know
we did a wisecrack edition on the Oscars
and we get into this how they give bad
awards sometimes for historical features
and for people that play other people
that was crap I will say king of award
speech season Brad Pitt yeah and and his
Oscar speech was okay just it throughout
he had one speech read some good jokes
he made fun of Quentin Tarantino's foot
fetish he introduced Leonardo DiCaprio's
nickname LD at one of them which was fun
he just had it he had fun
Brad Pitt had a very fun award season
good speeches great hair so I can't be
mad at him for that well great so it's
all about the hair first yeah and if
anyone does think of some chaps and
slaps that we didn't cover or you think
we missed hit us up but now it's time to
get into into the meat of this me
appetizer time is over it's time for
some main courses sir be we've we've
missed you we've missed your insights
we've missed everything about you so get
us started today what do you want us to
talk about so I want to talk about
loneliness I've been thinking about it a
lot lately
and I recently read about hikiko Mori
which is I think something that a viewer
encouraged us to look into I it might
have been due to bias when I'm not sure
about that guy so he Kiko Mori is a
phenomenon that originated in Japan but
has become known around the world and
other cultures and it's now considered a
psychological condition so he Kiko Mori
are reclusive individuals who often
don't leave their homes for months they
have few or no friends they are
depressed or experiencing overall
psychological distress and they avoid
social situations and it's estimated
that one and a half million people
suffer from this condition and this is
from a recent article published in The
Guardian imagine there was a virus you'd
never heard of which increased the
likelihood of mortality by 26% or a
condition that had a death rate
comparable to smoking 15 cigarettes a
day a national health crisis would be
declared and judging by the reaction to
the coronavirus panic would ensue this
public health crisis which leaves its
victims more than twice as likely to
develop Alzheimer's or other dementias
has a name loneliness and I've had
several conversations with friends in
recent months in which the word lonely
has come up and from what I've read
people feel embarrassed or uncomfortable
talking about loneliness it's like a
shameful secret that we all share but
not very many people talk about so I I
want to pause here and talk about
loneliness a little bit and learn about
your experiences and observations with
loneliness and do you agree that it's as
bad as research says it is
III do and not to go too deep into stuff
but yeah I think loneliness is something
that I know I've experienced a lot and
felt a lot I've had some periods of my
life where I really got in a pretty deep
holes because of that because feeling
and and I think the weird thing with
loneliness is you can sometimes feel
lonely even when you're around people
which i think is a part of this that
maybe we don't often think of we maybe
think of loneliness is like I'm home
alone with no one to talk to but I think
there's a sort of alienation or
isolation we can experience even when we
maybe feel like we don't fit or people
around us don't care about us or
understand us and things like that and I
know I felt that before specifically
when I was in grad school I had a chunk
of time where I just felt so lonely and
and the health stuff you bring up is
real because there's a connection
between how we feel mentally and like
our immune systems I'm not into hippie
stuff this is real and it it can you can
make us physically ill it can make us
more prone to having weakened immune
systems and like you said as well the
way in our society we struggle to talk
about mental health the way we talk
about physical health I think the stigma
around loneliness is super dangerous and
not good so I'm glad you're talking
about this yeah and I think what's
interesting as well is that and I do
this all the time so I'm implicating
myself as I think there's a kind of
millennial tongue-in-cheek like ironic I
[ __ ] hate everyone I just want to
like sit my like sit at home all day and
do nothing it was even listening to a
podcast that's like one of the first
sort of makeup artists influencers got
all these deals and she quit just
because she's like I I don't want to go
to parties I'd rather hang out with my
cat and I feel like I'd rather hang out
with my cat it's like a common refrain
and and there's nothing wrong with like
having alone time and stuff like that
and I'm there as well but I think we've
jokingly fetishized like staying at home
reading books all day or video games or
watching Netflix or anything like that
and again I I think maybe were even I'm
not thinking about like balancing that
with like oh like you should actually go
out there or even like the way I
complain when
and by the way I'm I'm not an [ __ ]
obviously like if someone needs help or
something I'm happy to help them but
just like random people who strike up
conversation with me for absolutely no
reason about like the weather god I hate
it so much but also maybe that's my
fault maybe I should be a better if you
are in the tri-state area and you see
Alec on the street riding his bike on
the New York public transit system
please go up to him talk to him about
the weather
yeah about you sir is this something
that like strikes a chord with you in a
in a personal way as well or just
something you think is important in an
intellectual way both I think it's
interesting because I I've been aware
that I've like had periods of my life in
which I felt lonely but I think in the
last few months like just having
conversations with friends who are at
all stages of their lives like married
single kids no kids traveling the world
study life at home everybody has said I
feel lonely or like there's like I feel
like I'm I don't have anybody even
though they're surrounded by everyone
and so what you said earlier when you
can be around a lot of people but still
feel lonely I think that's what
resonates most strongly with me like I
have a pretty big network of people in
my life like friends and family and then
just random humans that I can't seem to
get rid of in my life
and I still feel lonely sometimes and
it's amazing like you can be smiling and
laughing and inside you're just you just
feel you just feel like nobody else is
there with you mm-hmm it's interesting
is there like I'm kind of curious like
is there like what are not what are the
deeper reasons but is it you don't trust
the people or there's like a weird
subtext of like competition or like I
could understand like oh like I'm
laughing joking my coworkers but at the
end of the day I know they all [ __ ] me
over in a heartbeat it it I'm not saying
that's what what's happening but like
that those are sort of the things that I
imagine that could happen in that
scenario but but do you have any sense
of what
what causes it when you're around people
besides just feeling that I'm alone I'm
not sure I mean I'm sure that maybe it
has to do with like experiencing
depressive symptoms or maybe just
feeling more introverted at times but
also I'm very private about things so
sometimes like when people have really
like like when they want to talk about
something like very private and they're
all quite open about it I just don't
like that like I don't mind being very
open with some people but there are a
lot of times where I feel like I feel
very uncomfortable in situations where I
just feel alone because they don't want
to discuss things and I feel like it
closes me off like isolate myself from
those situations mhm I wonder how much
this has to do as well with a lack of
spaces of community building because I
think looking back historically and I
think religion is a good example of this
we've had these built in human
institutions that force us to get
together and be around each other and
whether that's religion or even you know
cafe or pub pub culture and old Europe
where people would hang out and talk
about ideas and be physically around
each other
I wonder concerts Phish concerts of
course I was gonna get into something
similar to that but but I do wonder like
there's a lack of I feel like spaces
these days and a society where we're
going increasingly secular society in
which more people than ever are working
remotely and not going into their office
spaces a society in which I even know a
lot of people who are in partnerships
and marriages where people work in
different cities different states in
different countries and can't be around
each other as much and something that
I've found not I guess hope at some
community and recently I've been going
to a lot more live concerts and
something I've noticed it shows these
days a lot more like handmade and unique
merch and I know this sounds like a
weird digression but more than I
remember in recent years you go to shows
and people are like hanging out before
sitting around afterwards chilling in
the parking lot drinking beer is selling
homemade shirts and I feel like it's a
space where people have been like hey we
all like this band or music together
[ __ ] it let's use this as an excuse to
have community to be together to know
that I share something with these people
and it could even be that like for
certain artists that speak to those
emotions we don't have to talk about it
but if me and you like that song I know
that we're on the same wavelength so I
wonder like do you mean do you all see
that as well that we don't have those
spaces we used to have or those spaces
have been turned into more atomized
places rather than community building
places I think there's definitely
resurgence Matt and I mean we've
previously talked about Grateful Dead
and fish as like a communal thing yeah
yeah I mean I haven't necessarily been
going to concerts but I've been going to
live events and I feel like the more
niche they are the better so I went to a
live show Radio Lab which is a great
positive mass and I actually had a great
conversation with random strangers
because like we were all into the things
that radio lab taught and that was like
our thing or I went to a trivia night
hosted by Atlus obscure which is a
website that does a lot of travel stuff
and it's weird because I'm you also it's
very easy to spot the people who this is
kind of like their circuit like they
just show up to these things hoping make
friends and and they're great people but
maybe they're little more socially
awkward and stuff and you know they'll
try to like insert themselves into a
group and it make friends which is it
was just great for them but you also
like really see the struggle that some
people deal with especially you know I I
think another not only is it like we
have sort of been atomized and don't
have our sort of public you know things
or we're not out in public like drinking
but I think like if you're a person
predisposed to like just having problems
with social skills maybe back in the day
you were just like forced around so many
people that you know you could it's
easier to sort of practice those or get
used to it or something like that but
now if you're not predisposed to being a
social butterfly like it's so much
easier to stay inside and then you're
like 35 you know like should I have no
friends and now I need to start going to
like meetups to meet new people and then
it's probably like pulling teeth at that
point not that I don't respect the
people who are trying to do that yeah so
this actually touches on my next point
which is a possible cure for loneliness
so last year the Guardian touched on
loneliness and discussed a group called
the Karis family which brings together
older locals and young professionals in
urban areas in the form of local
community networks there are different
like clubs and social groups that people
can join like singing drawing reading
whatever and the Karis family has been
shown to reduce isolation improve
relations across generations help people
feel happier and closer to community
they miss people less and they have more
people to rely on in times of need and
this reminded me a little bit of moais I
hope I'm pronouncing that correctly
there's social groups in social support
groups in Okinawa and they form lifelong
friendships in childhood and regularly
me into forever actually and researchers
credit my eyes with one of the reasons
why Okinawans have such long lifespans
so do you think that this is what we're
missing now these like groups these ways
to bring people together around a common
interest I mean yeah I was gonna say
earlier as well and in my experience in
recent experience I think anytime I've
like volunteered or got involved in some
sort of cause whether it be like social
political or creative I found that to be
an enriching and loneliness fighting
thing to do because it puts you around
people in your community who have
similar interests and passions who maybe
come to a space to work on a common
cause or towards a common goal and I
find that for me at least it's a way it
makes you feel a lot less alone in the
world to be around people in your
community that like care about the same
stuff I know that's not exactly what
seems to be happening in like Okinawa
but yeah I mean I think any space that
forces us together to care about each
other I think can help you know cure
this this damn loneliness disease a
little bit Alec what do you think yeah
and I think definitely I've seen
especially with older people pairing
them with younger
people whether it's like maybe people in
their 70s or 80s getting like a young
roommate who can help them with the
chores and stuff and you know pay rent
or maybe a discounted version of the
rent or you know obviously you can go to
your retirement home and sort of read to
people and stuff like that but I think
oh and then there was a another version
of this where I think older people in
retirement homes were watching like
small children I don't think super small
about like toddlers but I think all this
I mean you know when you get to that age
you're in a retirement home like a lot
of people might have dementia or other
cognitive problems and like let's say
you don't have those I think the lack of
connection can easily kind of just throw
a cutter we're like rot your brain
and then you're not moving around a lot
and then you're just like deteriorating
more and more and more and I think we're
starting to realize this just how
destructive like retirement homes are
for health I'm like looking for other
solutions of you know what to do in our
old age but I think sort of building
these relationships with younger is it's
it's good both ways right because like
you know it's not like if you're caring
for an older person even if it's just
helping them wash their dishes I think
it builds like a meaningful connection
and then you can get you know their
friendship out of it or their life
lessons or all those great things yeah
and I think it's like there's a weird
age stratification built into our
society where we often don't interact
with people that are wildly outside of
our age bubble that aren't like grandma
or grandpa and Judy or uncle Pablo or
something hey stop it
but like whether it's at whether you're
volunteering or you're at a an artistic
event or you're just like sitting at a
bar talking to someone thirty years
forty years older than you sitting there
as well I think there's something
valuable in that of of thinking about
people outside your age bubble as like
you whether whether whether you're older
you're talking to someone younger
whether they're younger and talking to
someone older we're all on this journey
together I know it sounds like I'm being
silly but I mean this and I think
there's something important in that
building relationships and networks
across age divides thinking about us is
all part of one thing
I agree I I think that's one thing that
I really like that my mom did when I was
growing up was that she was very adamant
that you can be friends with anyone at
any age
so one of my best friends at work is in
her late 50s and we talked about
whatever I mean we've had similar life
experiences she's at a different stage
in her life so she has a daughter who's
around my age but office gossip
transcends generations yes takeaway here
is that gossip is the way forward
find someone there coworkers you'll feel
much more connected yeah yes if you're
listening to this at work pause it get
up find a co-worker talk [ __ ] even if
it's making it up start a fake rumor
about someone for the sake that's before
we before we move on any last thoughts
on this or alternatively how about this
does anyone have any just a quick
thought if anyone's listening to this
and they're like [ __ ] I am experiencing
loneliness this is real for me any
thoughts on like a simple thing besides
talking [ __ ] about co-workers that
someone could do and I know none of us
are licensed mental health professionals
but so take this all the grain of salt
I've been meaning to do this but start
at the end a night hell yes
oh you don't have to find like a meet-up
com of D&D awesome D&D serving any
thoughts on a simple act someone can do
I think to identify what you're feeling
and I think like trying to externalize
emotions and feelings and try to just
identify and if you acknowledge
something like if you acknowledge I'm
lonely or I'm depressed or I'm blue I'm
down like identifying what you're
feeling I think is often quite helpful
because then you know what's going on
and I can try to make a plan to do
something about it and even if you don't
at least you know what is happening in
your life awesome I lied just quickly to
that something I realized that the
loneliest part of my life
I thought no one wanted to hang out with
me and I waited for people to reach out
to me because I thought no one wanted to
hang out with me only realized like a
decade later most people feel lonely
most people feel isolated people want to
hang so if you're thinking like you
don't get out there and do stuff because
no one wants to be around you and you
were
to make the first move [ __ ] that shoot a
text write an email people want to hang
out with you they feel the same way most
of us feel kind of lonely in crappy
inside know that we all put on our best
face hit your friends up hang out play
D&D go see some jazz paint a mural do
whatever I promise people want to hang
out with you Wow yes dude do crime maybe
car pranks I don't know what so let's
let's move on a little bit I think we
have a topic that Alec wants to get into
that involves hard science deep research
and a high level of medical attention
what are you getting into Alec I'm gonna
be talking about goop specifically goop
got a show on Netflix called goop lab a
lot of people were very upset about this
in fact real engineering Brian McManus
tweeted that he was automatic canceled
his Netflix subscription for those who
don't know goop is Gwyneth Paltrow the
actress she's a lifestyle brand they
famously sold a Jay a jade egg that one
puts in their vajayjay and also a
vampire sorry a psychic vampire
repellent I don't know if the vampires
are psychic or there's like psychic
vampire you know like psychics who
vampiric Li live off of your mental I
don't know but anyway the the after
mentioned Jade egg the the yoni egg I
believe it's called
was called dangerous by medical doctors
and goop was fined over $100,000 in
California for false advertising after
they said it could help bladder control
and hormone levels just to set the stage
this is all pre goop Bob's so wait wait
so that's sad because I need to call my
mom because I I was what I got it for
Christmas I wanted it to go well I did
not know this so you guys keep going I'm
gonna call her
[Laughter]
I hope you got her the psychic vampire
repellent not the Oni egg you know I'm
gonna plead the fifth on this one keep
going
so the Netflix series is six episodes I
watched it so you all don't have to they
send out goop staffers to try various
what they call modalities of treatment
and what's very interesting talking
about our last topic is a lot of it
deals
not necessarily with loneliness per se
but our sort of disconnection from each
other our sort of general spiritual
unwellness even though I hate the word
spiritual but you know I think they mean
sort of in that kind of general mental
way so these different modalities and
one they try anti-aging diets and
another they do psychedelics too for
their mental woes in another they do
energy healing and another to talk to a
psychic medium and there's a few things
that I thought were very very
interesting because I think I mean it's
easy to sort of laugh and say this is
pseudoscience and obviously it is
pseudoscience but I think there's like
some really kind of interesting things
going on first of all - that loneliness
not the loneliness topic like they are
kind of selling snake oil for I think
something that is a real concern they're
just selling a fake version of that so
in the psychedelic episode they really
talk about our societal disconnection
they talk about how we're all sort of in
it for ourselves we don't connect with
other people and you know just service
talking I think these are all real
issues and I'm not saying and Dave you
like shrooms etc as sort of a way to
connect with other people and you know
there are stuff it's sort of like some
psychedelics are sort of ego diminishing
so you feel small in relation to the
universe and that could be good for your
relation all that stuff but also they
just saw like a lot of self empowerment
and stuff like that and I think that
comes from sort of a real place but they
get into batshit eree which is I think
the second thing that I find really
interesting is they put the most
scientifically non controversial
episodes up front and slowly getting a
little crazier and crazier
so the first episode is about
psychedelics which have real scientists
or studying them to deal with anxiety
and depression and so me someone who's
like very skeptical this show soon is
turning on like oh are they not are they
not being [ __ ] about this like are
they doing real stuff they talk to
people with PhDs they talked to
psychiatrist in different episodes
there's the goop some of the goofs top
members or goop staff members are
research scientists or so they call
themselves
so that's the first episode
scientifically allegedly sound obviously
I'm not an expert I don't know if
there's like small claims they make that
aren't true
but the second has this guy wim HOF who
has this breathing technique that allows
you to like dive into very very cold
water I think it's also supported by
people some of the more like Silicon
Valley types and he's been involved in
some studies and I think what he's doing
there is taking like oh you know with my
breathing technique you can alter your
immune system which is you know like our
mental state can affect our cortisol
which regulates all that [ __ ] but then
he's like you know they injected me with
e-coli and I didn't get sick therefore
like I can control my immune system on
the molecular level and so that's just
like putting diving into the deep end so
to speak then they've got episodes about
like female pleasure and the anti-aging
diets which are different levels of
pseudoscience and then for the last two
they just go full woo woo which is
there's an episode on energy healing and
we actually have a clip of that can we
show that so this is a guy who
manipulates the energy fields around
your body and at various points people
like contort and look like they're
having an exorcism I'm kind of very yeah
and so they do that and then the last
episode they save the psychic medium
where they talk to your dead relatives
and so I think it's interesting that
they get you in there with their they
know what they're doing in that they get
you on board with a little like oh
here's some real science well what about
this super fake science another thing
they do is like they really like blur
the distinction a lot so they have these
interstitials which say like research
shows and we can pull one of those up
right now the most advanced research
thus far this is about MDMA has been
MDMA the compound found in the street
drug ecstasy in Mali in 2017 the FDA
assigned a breakthrough therapy
designation for MDA and psychotherapy
for PTSD that's one of the interstitials
there's another one research has shown
that Hoff's breathing technique this is
the ice water thing can cause the body
to temper
become more alkaline which is right then
by the then by the end they have it is
said they're talking about vampire
facials if we can go on to the next one
facial acupuncture not research shows is
said to increase blood flow and
stimulate the production of collagen so
again it's like oh I recognize this like
authoritative text but now it's no
longer saying research is just like
people say yeah sorry that's so bad oh
and even the alkaline thing is great
because that's one of the biggest scammy
things ever this weird notion that we're
supposed to be alkaline yeah but what do
you know about it I know about that that
Tom Brady the the quarterback from the
New England Patriots hate that guy has a
scam diet called the T b12 diet that he
developed with this scammy trainer and
dietitian and the main point of the diet
is to like is to like have alkaline
levels at a certain place and it's all
about like what foods do have alkaline
and don't and it's it's like a complete
scam like every actual scientist and
dietitian is like yeah this makes no
damn sense and if it helps you lose
weight it's just because it's dropping
out certain carbs and stuff like that
but Tom Brady he's kind of like goop for
people to listen to barstool sports or
something like that well so is there
anything in and you got it this a little
bit Alec were there any points in your
anthropological immersion in the goop
world that you took away as a positive
thing you could implement in your life
anything that you would actually think
of doing or using after your journey
well the one guys like you know he sort
of the wim hof got here's the thing if
you want to take a cold shower every
morning you feel energized for like good
for you like do you want to say that
that's gonna protect you from you coli
don't please don't do that but I'm not
gonna do that but it's one of those
things where I was like okay yeah take
it take a cold shower or like dive into
a cold lake or something like that
you do you that's for other stuff
I mean psychedelics man
I mean because that's legit I was
thinking when you said that I don't know
if they referenced it in the episode you
know there's the Michael Pollan book how
to change your mind that came out I
think last year that put together all of
the psychedelic research his read his
book is mostly about psilocybin and an
LSD not so much MDMA
but it's in conjunction with a lot of
research studies and all those stuff
they've been doing at Johns Hopkins in
recent years so that duck sounds legit
and there's I think a good amount of
research on that end a little ego death
never hurt anyone sir be are you a
member of the goop hive no I like to
pretend that I am but it actually makes
me really angry because I feel like it
they're like opportunists that are
trying to take advantage of people's
real problems like oh do this spiritual
healing so you can feel less lonely or
or do this you feel less depressed like
I don't like things like that I feel
like a lot of people are vulnerable
especially now people are stressed out
and there's so much bad information and
out there that people are desperate to
find a cure for whatever ails them and
when you have someone like Gwyneth
Paltrow promoting Jade eggs or whatever
vampire thing like it I don't know
people view celebrities as reliable
sources of information and I think that
she's weaponizing her notoriety and at
the expense of other people human oh
yeah and I took a turn and I think they
do this specific ly shitty thing in the
show cuz a lot of it is not necessarily
even at like Gwyneth Paltrow sort of
just like oh I'm curious about like tell
me about these things she's not saying
like this is she kind of distances
herself but they have these a little
they call them case studies where
they'll talk to people who have been
affected and in positive ways but really
you know they're just cherry-picking
something that fits their story but
specifically with the ice bath stuff
there's a guy what condition he had or
maybe he's in a car accident something I
think was a disease where he could
possibly become paralyzed and they're
like it's 50/50 or you know coin flip
whatever that you'll become paralyzed
from this and he's like and then I start
doing the ice bath thing and the
breathing and now not paralyzed it's
like well right they said it was 50/50
and and like again if this guy wants to
jump in a bath of ice that's fine but I
think it gives false hope like whether
it was the ice bath that did this or
whether it was that literal random
chance that the doctor already ascribed
but they do this with lots of things
whether you know they do it with people
who have taken psychedelics they do it I
think with some of the the energy
healing stuff like you know it really
helped me with X Y Z and I think it just
cells they cope to people and so I mean
that's how con artists work is that they
get at the real sort of sore point for
people their loneliness or their mental
health problems or whatever and then
sell them a fake cure-all yeah so
dangerous and I think the points are be
brought up earlier to about the way in
which we ascribe expertise to
celebrities is so dangerous and toxic
like just because you're a good actor
doesn't mean you know [ __ ] about science
politics philosophy religion the climate
or anything else and and the posturing
and the the way they exploit Authority
like the dam grifters they are to make
money is kind of gross sorry sorry
you're about to say something well I
agree exactly with what you're saying
and that was my problem with like all
these award speeches where people are
talking about like climate change and
you being unified and things like that
like who your job is to act and like to
provide that service not that you're not
allowed to have other opinions but don't
put yourself in a position of authority
and try to educate other people in that
way and what bothered me about that
those little like facts that were put up
on the screen was they took a grain of
truth like Oh acupuncture is can be used
for this acupuncture is good like I use
actual puncture for neck pain and things
like that and it really helps but when
you say things like acupuncture is great
to produce collagen I don't like that
like and that's exactly what con artists
do they take like a grain of truth and
then they to
des and I it just makes me so mad
because I feel like people just they
don't know and they're they really want
help yeah yeah I hate when it paltrow
well and there's examples of celebrities
that can use their influence in better
ways I stand pretty hard for my guy Adam
McKay the director and comedy writer but
something I think the who made like
Talladega Nights and anchorman and the
Big Short and you know what other movies
but something that's cool that he's done
recently he started his own production
company cuz an issue that matters for
him is climate science and stuff like
that so he just started his own company
where he's putting money behind actual
like scientists and experts to make
audio and video content on that sort of
stuff but he's not running around acting
like he is somehow a scientist because
he's not so instead he's using his
influence to bring up people who
actually have that expertise and with
someone like Paltrow as well I'll say
this
you called her foul earlier good actor
why did she quit doing the thing that
she's good at to just sell [ __ ] and
and and vagina eggs I it's so stupid
this would be like if Alec left
wisecrack to go somewhere and and start
a cart selling like probiotic ice cream
it would suck and it wouldn't taste good
but he's really good at what he does now
I don't get it I when I do get it cuz
there's more money in it which is the
gross part about it she can make a lot
more money doing nothing than she would
make in movies well she says in the
intro that plays over every episode is
she's like you know I I didn't want to
just be making out with Matt Damon and
movies for rest of my life I'm something
meaningful and I think an interesting
thing and I'm sure this applies as much
to Tom Brady as it does to Gwyneth
Paltrow or even you know anti-vaxxer
splatter I think and I can't prove this
I think they believe it in earnest right
I think cuz like winneth Paltrow is all
about she's all about like you know I'm
just it's almost very like vice like
punk rock like I'm just gonna like
experiment with it and like I don't know
I don't like I'm skeptical about I won't
keep an open mind like yeah like
psychics might not be real but holy [ __ ]
they just described my great and I think
that's like another little trick they
use whether knowingly or not is
they sort of weaponize like a sort of
carefree gonzo style of like journalism
to be like whatever like I'm just gonna
try an energy healing and see what
happens like oh this thing happened that
like I can't explain but science
probably can in a much more easy way
like yeah I guess it works but like
that's just my experience and so yeah
like I don't think she's sitting there
being like I'm lying to people I think
she thinks she's helping which is even
she thinks more worrying then I'd rather
have her be a grifter the knew she was
telling Tripp [ __ ] then someone who
actually has you know got high off her
own supply I think it's disappointing
that she doesn't think that acting was
meaningful I mean you have a talent in a
skill to help people escape from
everyday life like that is that's
amazing if people can watch your work
and forget about I don't know problems
at home their health whatever and I
think that's incredibly meaningful she
should have stuck with that because that
made more of a difference in people's
lives than the Jade egg I currently have
shoved up my badge I know it's hard to
because since I don't have a vagina it's
been in my but there's a whole time and
the chairs in the studio are not soft I
want to end the podcast so I can and pop
it out but I got a call a doctor after I
call my mom but I agree with you and it
is it's horrible that Gwyneth Paltrow
devalues art as something that can make
people's lives better over this and the
idea that that film or or stage plays or
literature aren't things that profoundly
affect people's lives in great ways I
mean to touch back on the last topic it
by lonely as points like reading books
and watching movies really helped me
find some happiness in connection with
human themes not you know frigging witch
potions that you put in your tip of your
penis or whatever it is she's doing I
don't like it well so we need to wrap
this one up a quick question though if
you all had your own lifestyle brand
what sort of stuff would you sell to
really promote your lifestyle to others
Alec I'll start with you
[ __ ] way cancer we go first okay surgery
okay I'll go first of all you think then
if I had a lifestyle brand it would be a
service where oh it'd be like a store
and these already exist but it primarily
be books booze and a really good vinyl
section so you could come in my store
you'd hear some good old music we'd have
a nice selection of natural wines and
craft beers and in a curated selection
of books both fiction and nonfiction
that would be my lifestyle nothing going
in any hole whatsoever this is not
because you said I I thought of it right
before you said but like a like a book
of the week club mmm let's start our own
cult okay I would like that you have a
book of the week Club you maybe write a
little like intro for why you think this
is important I like it right I did many
people have to worship me as the supreme
leader of the universe oh no yeah you
use this to become God obviously serving
what are you selling to the one week
maybe I would sell like a service like
Oh something that could like help people
like I'll review your resumes or like
that's a thing that exists and you could
just do that exactly okay get in touch
with surbhi I think we talked about this
earlier starting rate is $1000 per
resume but it's worth it cash only we
need to keep this off the books so the
taxman don't come a-knockin so to wrap
things up is it is it okay if I talk
about something as well yeah okay just
want to make sure I'm in so much fun
it's great being back I wish we could
each do eight topics and be here all day
so something you might have heard of if
you're a human with eyes to see ears to
hear and a tongue to taste is the
coronavirus panic it's been one of the
major news stories and definitely the
biggest public health stories in 2020 so
a little background I'm sure we all know
this but the corona virus of course is a
a corona virus corona virus itself isn't
a thing it's a type of virus this this
batch started in Wuhan China and it's
meant to have a merge from a seafood and
poultry market now it's a moderately
infectious
so it's similar to SARS if we remember
the SARS panic from a few years back one
person with this corona virus could
spread it to between 1.5 and 3.5 people
so moderately infectious not
over-the-top
now this 2019 version of the corona
virus is when the first emerge is more
infectious than either SARS or MERS the
last two comparable diseases are viruses
but are less likely to death
so more infectious less likely to kill
you now as of right now the risks to
people outside of China remains very low
and we can get into this more later if
you are listening to this from the
anywhere outside of China the risk of
seasonal flu is significantly higher and
more real for you than coronaviruses
okay a couple related facts currently
there's still 20 Americans and a bunch
of other people I hate when I have to be
like Americans like they're somehow
different but there are 20 Americans
that are currently infected on a boat
quarantined at a Japanese port which
sounds very horrible there's over 400
people stuck on this boat with limited
rations stuck in their little tiny
cabins the Chinese economy is currently
struggling pretty bad the new york times
had a quote that said it's like europe
and the medieval times things have kind
of shut down economically and as of the
most recent count and this might have
changed because in the past three days
that i've been keeping up with this the
numbers keep changing 1016 people are
dead because of this strain of
coronavirus and in currently 12 people
in the united states have been infected
six of them being in California so
California has the most much like the
electoral college oh we got the biggest
number there now there is I'll say two
more things and then we'll give it to
the panel but right now according to
most scientists the best case scenario
is containment that we keep corona virus
contained to where it started don't let
it spread what was about to say oh yeah
yeah so that's kind of like the
best-case scenario but a lot of experts
think this is increasingly unlikely so a
couple
quotes here this is from a group of
scientists at the University of Hong
Kong one of them said independent
self-sustaining outbreaks of and they're
calling it 2009 coronavirus in major
cities globally could become inevitable
because of substantial exportation of
pre-symptomatic cases so basically
saying like it's gonna be pretty hard to
contain because of pre-symptomatic
exportation one of the same science said
I can imagine a scenario where this
becomes a fifth endemic human
coronavirus so we already have four
coronaviruses that are sort of in the
rotation of endemic viruses they're
talking about this becoming the fifth
one however that's striking panic in to
anyone's heart same scientist says and
the scientist named Stephen Morris we
don't pay much attention to them because
they're so mundane especially compared
to seasonal flu so it's looking like
this might become part of our roster of
diseases that happen all the time but we
already have four corona viruses that we
could have even gotten at one point and
Richard webby and influenza expert at
st. Jude's Research Hospital says for
the most part the for existing corona
viruses cause common cold type symptoms
so that's what we're getting from the
corona viruses that are currently out
there now
if one option is that it sort of floats
into this rotation of currently existing
corona viruses the worst option are the
more dangerous one is that it returns as
a bad seasonal flu and something that we
can expect year in and year out
scientists are saying the odds of this
are pretty good and what we might be
seeing is the emergence of a new corona
virus that could very well become
another seasonal pathogen that causes
pneumonia that said it would still be
more it would be more than a cold less
than SARS
the only other pathogen I can compare it
to is seasonal influenza that's Michael
osterholm of the University of Minnesota
right there so while the best case
scenario is containment it is looking
like there's a good chance that this is
going to become a part of our normal
disease roster now the thing I think we
should maybe talk about of course this
is real it's affecting people in China
it rates much higher than the rest of
the world but people in America are
freaking out if anyone's traveled in
America recently there's a lot of people
like wearing mad
which actually don't help you unless you
if you already have it's great to wear
masks if you don't have it it's doing
nothing for you there's been issues of
students from China or just of Chinese
descent being made fun of mocked or
bullied in high schools and colleges
around the country at one school in
Toronto a group of parents tried to get
students of Chinese descent sent home
from school yeah there's a lot of
panicky stuff going on and of course
this is all against the backdrop of the
thing that could kill us is the flu the
thing we should worry about is people
that are not in China is the flu and we
still as a country are wildly under
vaccinated when it comes to the seasonal
flu so I've said too much already
thoughts on this are are we are we
overreacting to the corona virus are we
reacting appropriately should we all be
locked up in our homes I I'm really
interested in the panic part and I think
the best thing I heard was there was a
guy who wrote he was on NPR talking
about it wrote a book about zoonotic
diseases which is what this is it came
from animals into humans I was like oh
we should take it really seriously but
we shouldn't panic and the example you
gave about the face mask is that if
you're coughing and spewing up mucus
like put a face mask on the it's really
great at containing that so you don't
infect other people but it doesn't
really do much to protect you from
people who are sick and so regardless of
that people are still go like doing runs
on face masks at stores so he was
talking about he went in somewhere in
Montana or somewhere in that part of the
country you know not exactly the most
densely populated area where they were
all sold out at the at the CVS and so
that kind of [ __ ] drives me insane you
know I recently flew to California and
there was a bunch of people wearing face
masks and I actually love you you often
notice people there's like more of a
culture in China of like oh I'm sick or
even vaguely symptomatic I'm gonna wear
a face mask like oh maybe yeah when
reality is probably just a bunch of
people trying to protect themselves yeah
but I think a thousand people have died
from the corona virus so far which is
obviously awful but like I think in
America the flu virus every year kills
like
thirty thousand sometimes or fifty
thousand well yeah even more so just to
interject really quick in 2014 the flu
is the eighth most common cause of death
in America with 57,000 deaths which was
less than a number of deaths from the
worst year of the AIDS epidemic so not
to downplay the AIDS epidemic but like a
bad flu year is as bad as it can get
we're talking to high numbers of deaths
so go ahead but yes you're absolutely
right and I think the other panicky part
is that I don't know the specific
breakdown but I think a lot of the
mortalities are probably people who are
very young very old obviously that's
still tragic or people with like you
know compromised immune systems we have
HIV whether they had a bone-marrow
transplant or have cancer or anything
like that you know so for you to be a
fully healthy person freaking the [ __ ]
out and saying oh my god I'm gonna die
or you know there's been a lot of like
tick tock like this is the the end
plague kind of jokes but I also think
there's like an element of truth and
what people are thinking about it and I
don't really know at what point like the
media is stoking this like again like
you don't want to underplay right
because you know before you know have
all the facts about a virus or you know
any sort of pandemic or epidemic you
want to take it seriously and get sort
of scare people enough to make them
cautious but you don't want them to you
know buy all all the face masks of
people that can't use them yeah the
media coverage in China isn't as
fear-based as it is here in the states
but one thing to consider is that the
media is controlled by the state so it
could be due to censorship but yeah they
were shutting down some of the early
stories wasn't the best look for them
early on yeah I think it's interesting
that the World Health Organization is
more concerned about what they're
calling is an info Demick which is an
overabundance of information that some
of it is accurate and some isn't and it
makes it difficult for people to find
trustworthy sources of info and reliable
guidance so apparently they're working
24/7 to identify the most prevalent
rumors
online and they're updating their social
media channels with evidence-based
information so that people know what
works and what doesn't and how to keep
themselves safe yeah I mean an
interesting part of this and you you
kind of pointed to this is oh you know I
think you was it was the term info
Demick you used yeah so there is an
article from a few days ago from
Business Insider about the psychological
side of this and just a quote from it
said psychological research shows novel
threats raise anxiety levels more than
familiar threats and the people tend to
under react to familiar threats so this
idea that the things that might actually
hurt is we don't react to but the
novelty of something less dangerous a
list it's a much more intense response
and I thought this was an interesting
fact says for example there's about a
one in seven chance that heart disease
will be the cause of an American's death
that's a lot whereas the chance they
will die at the hands of a foreign-born
terrorist is one in 45,000 808 but
according to a 2016 Chapman University
survey of American fears terrorist
attack on nation and victim of terrorism
both ranked among the top five worries
of respondents above heart disease which
is going to kill one at seven so the
psychology around this it's pretty wild
and the way in which we and I want to
blame I don't want to like anxiety blame
people because I love anxiety I have it
all the time for dumb things but there's
this weird sort of like cooked in
unconscious narcissism that something
happens halfway around the world and our
response is like it's definitely coming
for me in particular there's billions of
people on this planet but it is from
China it knows where I live it's coming
for me and I'm going to die and I think
this while I'm eating like a bacon egg
and cheese with a level of saturated fat
that's just like making my heart slow
down yeah I think there's a little bit
of narcissism there yeah I also really
like the the novel threats I mean this
is exactly why we don't Flippa [ __ ]
about the flu even though it kills way
more people than this like new scary
virus yeah and then so here I'm gonna
I'm gonna be aggressive right now who
has gotten their flu shot this year
that's
only on this podcast I have sir be do I
see a hand sir be you've not kind of oh
I'll tell you why oh wow I I'm not sure
if I told you guys that I had a horrible
reaction to that Oh Titus a vaccine and
I had hives
they called it chronic idiopathic
urticaria for two years so my entire
body was covered in hives for Jesus and
ever since then my allergist told me to
lay off vaccines okay because after that
I got the flu vaccine and I had a
horrible reaction to that as well so she
said to get off of it for a little bit
do you know I I don't know if you got
this one but so the flu vaccine is they
breathe the virus in egg in eggs like
chicken eggs and so if you're allergic
to eggs you can have a reaction but they
also have a version that's not grown in
in egg cells yeah I know about that so I
was planning to get that this year but I
think the fear of like having another
owners reaction kept me from it so the
one person I want yah but I'd say
everyone listening the one exception on
planet earth for not getting the flu
vaccine is servi if you're a name is
that sir B and you are not a host of
culture bench on wisecrack you need to
get a flu vaccine there is a go ahead
down well for Class A I think the dumb
thing is like oh I like again like the
flu probably won't kill me like if I got
it but I'm gonna get it because it will
be when I'm walking around sniffling and
very Contin times you're violent before
you show symptoms or at the onset of
symptoms so like I'm sniffling around on
a subway getting a bunch of people sick
and they go home and they give granny a
hug and now granny's dead and like yeah
you know that that's on me there's a
healthy what do I need it for like
you're literally killing someone's
grandmother or you know you're killing
someone's like cousin or whatever with
cancer or something like that yeah
there's an article I think it's from a
year or two ago now but you can look it
up in the New York Times about herd
immunity
the idea that immunity is not an
individual thing and getting a vaccine
isn't really just an individual benefit
it's a communal benefit
then we need to think about health and
infectious disease as members of a
community of people and not just as
singular isolated individuals to touch
back to the loneliness thing just like
when we feel lonely we got to remember
we're a part of a community when we feel
sick or we don't feel sick we're also a
part of a health-based community and and
things like getting a flu vaccine
washing our damn hands staying home if
we're sick are so big and things we
might not be thinking about while we're
worried about the corona virus because
the flu and I don't want to stoke panic
in anyone the flu has a much better
chance of killing you or really messing
you up than most things that you are
currently worrying about so it's
something we should be taken seriously
and this did make me think and I think
this is kind of related about one bummer
is we all know the best thing you can do
if you're sick stay home
you should not go to work or school if
you are sick but of course tons of
people don't get paid sick leave that
sucks so it creates like public health
issues when people feel that pressure to
go into work and that that bums me out
it's a bummer yeah thank God we're all
digital so all of us could be infectious
right now and we're not in the same room
I think we've solved the corona virus so
we solved that everyone should work
remotely no but in that that gets no
then that makes the loneliness problem
bad so we pick one we can be lonely
without corona virus or part of a human
community and wildly infected oh no
we'll solve it we put eggs up our butts
we get in the office together the eggs
neutralize the virus were together so we
have community we're not lonely did we
just solve everything we do this because
we come together with three disparate
ideas that a spiritual energy and force
is using in concert to come together at
a glorious moment to solve all of
humanity's ills
any last thoughts on the corona virus
are we comfortable that we solved it
cool and people don't you don't freak
out wash your hands get a shot don't go
to work if you're sick if your boss says
you have to go to work giving my number
I'll talk to him or her okay so before I
wrap up once again I wish we could just
be here forever it's so fun to be back
it's time to get into some listener
voicemails but before we do that we want
to hear from you all so if you wanna
give us a call the number is two one
three five three four eight eight zero
seven that's two one three five three
four eight eight zero seven if you want
to email us culture binge at wisecrack
dot Co there is no M wisecrack dot Co
there is no M so what's getting some of
the voicemails we have right now okay so
this one is from anonymous so this is
the global hacker group they left us a
message I think or it's just a person
that want to remain anonymous we'll find
out hey culture benders I'm calling to
leave a possible topic for you guys to
discuss I was really interested in the
video wisecrack put out about the Oscars
or just kind of the history of it and
whether or not they should be considered
significant or even supported in any way
and so I'd love for you guys to dive
into that a little deeper maybe instead
of just presenting one side of it you
could play double axes advocate and go
back and forth and talk about what some
of the possible pros might be such as
bringing a wider audience to some less
known films just generally creating
discourse around films that otherwise
would be there wow I didn't know that
hackers were also interested in the
movies that's wonderful yeah so if
anyone who's hasn't seen it yet we do
have a really great video up right now
asking the questions where the Oscar is
a mistake and this delightful caller
thinks we should talk about that some I
mean I think we could we could talk
about that at some point I don't know if
we have time right now
any quick takes on the Oscars being good
or bad I feel very conflicted because
like our whole point of that video and
it doesn't invalidate the video is that
the Oscar tends to go for safe choices
where people transform into historical
figure like Freddie Mercury or something
like that
things that are controversial tend not
to win because of the voting system and
then things that have historically won
in the past
you look like singing the the rain
didn't win whereas you know that year
some other like when you look at the the
very important films like 2001 a Space
Odyssey you know like more popular stuff
those are the things that necessarily
win best picture or other Oscars it's
usually some garbage you've never
heard of at the same time like I don't
know Paris like one level of parasite
and I think it deserve to win and so I
don't know I feel like they're gonna use
that a like there's this like
psychological phenomenon where you do
one good thing and use it to excuse a
bunch of shitty behavior like oh like I
voted for Obama so I'm gonna be a raging
racist for the next eight years and I
feel like the the Academy's gonna be
like we voted for parasite so now we can
go straight back to nominating the green
book ya know just to quickly piggyback
on that you have nineteen seventeen
would have won I would be like yes
anonymous caller we need to take it down
the Oscars are trashed but because Paris
I did so well yeah I'm like the person
that's like never mind they're good
again I like I think the Oscars has a
role I think there's a lot that's wrong
with it but I I do think that it's nice
to see what what films are out there and
to get an understanding of what goes
behind making a film like cinematography
costume like things like that like
things that I wouldn't that I take it
for granted I think it's nice to have
that reminder that there are so many
people involved in creating a film yeah
yeah and just you know what these things
are is important as we make them so
there you go
but maybe we'll talk about this more
another time and thank you so much for
that suggestion anonymous here's Maddie
who called us as well hi this is Maddie
calling for cult revenge I've recently
read a couple articles in The New York
Times and Fox about something called
dopamine fasting that is the newest
Silicon Valley
woowoo [ __ ] and thanks enjoy
everything you do Maddie you get us you
just get it wait have you all heard
about this dopamine fasting thing no I
only know a little bit about it's like
the dumbest [ __ ] I've ever heard so we
know like dopamine is a chemical that
our brains release when we're like happy
and feeling good so it's like it's the
reward chemical specific yeah so it's
like I don't know if you're like if
you've really ruined your brain it's
like if you're playing some game on your
phone and you get to a new level
you get dopamine so that the
corporation's can own your mind a little
more or it can be like you know someone
says you did a good job at work or your
partner is kind to you whatever it is so
I think the basic idea is you do stuff
to like choke your brain out you deprive
it of the things that make it feel good
so that so that later you have more kind
of like an old boxing movies when they
would say the boxers like weren't
allowed to have sex before fights
because somehow having nothing make the
leg legs we have don't ejaculate and
you'll be better at fighting it's but
it's like that for Silicon Valley people
to do business more good yeah there
there is a component of this that I'm
interested in which is I think our
phones and mobile games are hijacking or
brain chemistry to make us do awful
things and I'm kind of like oh I'd like
to disconnect from that but the idea
that you can fast like dopamine is what
makes your brain work in all kinds of
ways and I think this is why I think a
lot of antidepressants work on dopamine
receptors in Lund correct because when
they don't work and your brain doesn't
have enough dopamine you're [ __ ]
and so the idea that you could actually
fast from it I think is just purely
scientific garbage although I'd have to
look into it a little bit more because
you're always getting it your brain is
just always using it for all these
different things but the idea of fasting
from maybe the bad dopamine hijacking
things in our lives whether or not
there's like a scientific basis for it I
still there might be like you know like
I could log off Twitter's what I'm
saying yeah I mean if you really have
dopamine problems that a neurochemical
level talk to a psychiatrist about
antidepressants it could help you if
you're looking at your phone too much
and I'm really upset that the name of
this author is missing for my brain
right now I don't know if you all read
this book it's called how to do nothing
and I think it the author is Jenny
something a really great book and I feel
so bad that I forgot the author's last
name because one of the best books I've
read in the last year but in how to do
nothing she gets it the idea that we're
insanely it addicted to phones and
screens and speed and all these sorts of
things and talks about ways to
disconnect from that in healthy manners
that aren't just like dopamine fasting
that sounds like a better version it's a
much better version yeah it's so so dumb
it's like I wish I wish
I had that much money where I can come
up with these like stupid things to like
keep my life exciting and new like if I
get another round of funding like if I'm
in my series D and it's like well what
do I do now oh I know let's let's do
some dopamine fasting like that's just
stupid like I wish that was a problem I
think you could really solve all your
problems by making money off of coming
up with these dumb suggestion sir be
like you need to create you need to be a
dopamine fasting consultant to the
millionaires and the billionaire's of
Silicon Valley you need to be on the
next season of goop lab and talking
about how we need to fast from I don't
know just make some [ __ ] up what do you
want to fast from we need to fast from
water
nobody can drink water anymore it's
coca-cola it's either acidic or basic
but like it'll somehow will make you
alkali well anything that makes me
alkaline I will do I'm gonna go suck on
a Duracell after this to make sure I get
as much alkaline in my body as possible
I'm not gonna do that no one knew that
we don't an email that's like my my son
is in the hospital because you listen to
your dumb podcast and sucked on a
double-a until he got sick well I think
once again we could go for hours I'm
sure listeners you're wishing we could
keep going for hours but we got to leave
some in the tank so to speak so we come
back in two weeks we have that hot hot
heat for you I'm in the meantime the
people want to hear from you they want
to interact with you they want to see
what you're up to so sir B where can our
listeners slash viewers get in touch
with you and see what you got going on
tweet me sir e Patel 22 awesome Alec
where can the people have more wisecrack
Alec so simple so great I mean find me
on Twitter at Michael o burns I think
it's the same on Instagram but why does
it matter what does any of it mean fast
from dopamine instead this has been the
first of many culture binges from 2020
we were so glad that you were here and
we'll be back in two weeks to dive
deeper into what's going on in the
zeitgeist thanks for sticking around and
we will see you soon
[Music]